I also just appreciate that that's
scrolling through the comment box for
this everything either says lin-manuel
Miranda or I'm Mary Poppins y'all push
yeah I didn't really even care that much
for guardians of the galaxy too but with
that that that's just a part of culture
now thanks yondu what shake and reject
nation happy monday happy post oscars
day hope you all had a good night last
night did you watch the oscars are you
excited I'm a man Jordan peeled to come
the original screenplay category so I'm
over the moon pretty much anything else
is just gravy on top of that but uh
really happy for shape of water happy
for Francis McDormand happy for Gary
Oldman Coco and Dunkirk cleaning up some
of the technical stuff The Dukes the
Dukes finally within that cinematography
award pretty cool spoiler alert if y'all
didn't see the Oscars but anyway they
dropped a new trailer during the show
that's right just a spoonful of trailers
helps that Oscar ceremony go down and
there's a new Mary Poppins movie coming
our way starring none other than Emily
Blunt directed by Rob Marshall the the
musical guy so uh why don't we check
that out here we go
mmm-hmm go on dreary
[Music]
[Music]
Oh lin-manuel
[Music]
we have a weapons to see you bad I mean
you know this is a basic teaser but uh
for Christmastime I think that's gonna
be pretty fun these days I guess I get a
little conflicted about these revivals
it seems like we are going back to a lot
of the classics and mining those for new
material either to rebrand in a darker
more gritty light or just to expand upon
or recreate in the live-action setting
and each one is a little different I
guess it's sort of a hit and miss trend
for me some of them turn out
surprisingly good and others turn out
you know kind of all right and this one
has definitely got me curious at least
from this trailer I like the approach
they took of just showing kind of one
sequence I do have to say I'm just
waiting for somebody to recut this
trailer with Pennywise because this is a
lot like watching georgie follow his
boat except it's a kite and instead of a
gutter it's the sky and instead of a
clown there's like a floating woman with
an umbrella
so but that aside as much as i was a
little skeptical going into this trailer
i do like just this simple approach to
this you know i don't know how it'll
look when we get like an actual
theatrical trailer that has like plot
elements and more dialogue and things
but just from the outset here I like the
dreary version of London they've drawn
here I like the mood of that a lot of
the colors really pop to like the greens
especially the blues the reds and Emily
Blunt I mean we only get a brief moment
of her as the character but you know
she's really charming and I believe that
she's a pretty good choice for this role
it's gonna be hard to top Julie Andrews
for sure and that's always kind of a
hazardous thing going into one of these
movies is how much is it the character
versus how much it is the person who
portrayed them but I feel like Emily
Blunt is certainly capable of this
I feel like this movie could easily have
a lot of charm it looks very elegant and
thought-out in just the way these shots
move anyhow and you've also got
lin-manuel Miranda in here which you
know yeah I mean he's popular as ever
and I quite like him I mean I'm
the music from Hamilton I've seen him in
various appearances and stuff I think
he's got a lot of charisma he's very hot
right now but I think he's a good spirit
to bring into this project and it says
here he's playing a Lamplighter I guess
the The Apprentice - Bert from the
original film played by Dick Van Dyke
obviously just reading about the
connections to the original this this
gives me sort of a cautious optimism it
seems like there may be approaching this
from a tasteful perspective it's kind of
an interesting place to enter this from
I like that this isn't just pandering it
doesn't seem to be any way in terms of
this trailer I like this sort of conceit
that we're going back years later we're
picking up with the same kids but now
grown up and she's stopping in to you
know sort of touch their lives again I
believe after some kind of personal loss
has taken place that's sort of the gist
I got from the logline
just as a simple teaser this got me more
pleasantly intrigued than I actually
thought I was gonna be like I said I
went into this a little bit cynical and
I'm looking forward to seeing a little
bit more you know I grew up with this
movie like a lot of people did spoonful
of sugar and I mean you know ultimately
it's gonna come down partly to those
elements but also just to the music and
how it functions as a musical in the
spirit of those classic Disney
live-action musicals I hope that they
keep true to that especially now cuz we
don't get a ton of like live-action
musical films like the greatest showmen
recently impressed me with the way they
handled that I don't always love Rob
Marshall's direction when it comes to
musicals and stuff I wish you would kind
of showcase at least some of the dancing
some of the more musical elements a bit
better you know obviously this is this
is gonna kind of live and die by how
good how memorable how rich the music is
because the original film anyway has so
many memorable songs I mean you know
spoonful of sugar
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious chim
chiminey like there's so many memorable
songs and a lot of the recent musicals
I've seen tend toward a very poppy sonic
style a very polished style that's gonna
be a major element to the success to the
efficacy of this movie and I'm not
really familiar with the two guys who
are doing the music for this but you
know fingers crossed man because if
there's anything I thought could have
been a little better about some of the
greatest showmen just recently and some
of the other musical things I've seen
lately in general is just that there is
that overbearing or at least to me it's
kind of over
pop sensibility pop influence on the
songs and especially for this going back
to a period piece I really hope that
they don't air toward that as much not
that everything has to be super
traditional but Mary Poppins it seems
like it might be less appropriate to
take it from a pop environment
especially since it is still like you
know the early 20th century that they're
doing here but yeah just based off this
little tease here I'm pleasantly
surprised and I'm looking forward to
seeing more and like I said especially
around Christmastime I feel like if they
nailed this this could be really
wonderful really heartwarming so what do
you guys think are you excited for for
Mary Poppins returns Mary Poppins
returns leave us a comment in the box
below share your thoughts and as always
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
updated every time a review or a video
is out hit us up on the Stardust app
link in the description box follows
first over there helps us out and also
check out viewer reviews.com it's like a
personal rotten tomatos tailored to your
specific tastes it's a lot of fun over
there those are where we're putting up a
lot of our written reviews as well so
come check us out over there and until
next time guys Cheers